hallo mein name ist luca wöhrle liebe
freunde ich darf euch heute nacht zwei
wochen pause aufgrund meiner krankheit
endlich wieder begrüßen und weiter neue
wie sonne
hier ist ja in jedem moment mann der es
mit luca video der fall ist ist auch das
heutige video wieder freundlich
unterstützt wurden von google play im
rahmen der playon kampagne und heute
meine lieben freunde spielen wir das
spiel minecraft ja ich glaube jeder
kennt minecraft von daher muss ich da
nicht so viel zu sagen wir spielen
allerdings hier minecraft auf meinem
google pixel und wir sind allerdings
auch nicht in einer singleplayer welt
und ich war hier noch mal eben was rum
nein nein er viel zu langweilig wir sind
online auf meinen plex einem coolen
server und wir spielen heute mal wieder
richtig oldschool nostalgie schmissig
survival games die sache ist allerdings
ich weiß überhaupt nicht wo ich das hier
spielen kann und ich war vorhin schon
mal drauf aber das hat der server
komplett anders aus drei sättel befinden
uns jetzt hier schon in dem spiel
ihr seht schon jeder spieler ist auf
seiner position und in drei sekunden
gehts los
1 und co alle laufen jetzt
wahrscheinlich in die mitte ich laufe
allerdings erst mal weg von daher direkt
hier sprinten aktiviert haben wir direkt
meine erste kiste und in der kiste ist
drin okay wir haben
okay wir haben ein schwert ich brauchte
schwert hier ok schnell so
welch eine angreift
schlage ich okay
okay wir ihnen leider kommt wollte da
vorne getötet werden wenn keiner kommt
da laufe ich halt weiter weg ich bringe
mal hier vorne in die höhle reihen haben
wir auch noch eine kiste das blöde bei
oh mein gott was liegt da alles drin
oh mein gott auch noch essen und so das
krasse halbwaise beide games ist dass
die ganze gegend einen wert von hinten
kommen kann und ein halt irgendwie töten
kann
seit ein bisschen stressig allerdings
verstecke ich mich erstmal hier hinter
dem glas und ziehe mir meine rüstung
anderen packe mir auch den pfeil und das
essen und einen mann schnell auswahl
inventarsystem jr ward und diakonie
immer weiter die höhe treibt da stehen
mein gott
er tötet mich doch safe guck mal was
sehr viele krasse rüstung hat und ich
kann nicht mal richtig laufen gibt noch
eine chance sich noch weg ich noch weg
ich bin tot
ich habe vor lange nicht weiter haft
gespielt also entschuldigen ich bitte
wunder nummer zwei freunde geht's hier
komplett schlag auf schlag
die runde ist gar nicht mal so voll wie
ihr seht hier sind viele freie plätze
von daher laufe ich auch wieder nicht
direkt in die mitte sondern direkte weg
von den ganzen leuten
ich lass doch mal die kisten nach vorne
stehen nicht meine welt ist ja immer
riesig weiß sowie games ich weiß nicht
ob es ja auch der fall ist ist die welt
nach einer gewissen zeit verkleinert
wird allerdings laufe ich jetzt erstmal
so weit ich kann und schaue hier ganz
hinten mal nachsitzen nach rechts steht
auch einer der mich gesehen hab ich
jetzt das material dafür dass dies so
weit weg jetzt sind wir vernünftige
sachen drin
ok dann ziehen wir uns erst mal unsere
schutzkleidung an genau und nehmen uns
in den pfeil kann ich jetzt trotzdem mit
dem bogenschießen
ja das war mein fall grund war glaube
ich auch noch eine kiste genau hier
links dann schauen wir noch mal kurz
rein das war schon früher einmal meine
taktik beim 1
die ganzen sachen habe ich schon ist
allerdings war das schon früher einmal
bei minecraft sowie games meine taktik
die anderen sollen alle in die mitte
laufen ich bin auf einfach nur weg also
das ist für mich auf jeden fall gerade
kompletten nostalgie moment hier meine
ganze vorgehensweise ich weiß auch noch
früher auf harvey hießen die server hype
irgendwie so neheim pixel und eine flex
auf dem ich jetzt gerade drauf habe mein
gott
okay ist ja auch ordentlich was gutes
drin wahrscheinlich alle leute die so
die ganze zeit minecraft zweiten spiel
der gruppe
ich hab dich einmal getroffen
fliegender wechsel meine lieben freunde
machen wir direkt weiter mit der
nächsten runde und ich bleibe auch
weiterhin bei meiner taktik bestehen
also ich werde jetzt nicht irgendwie
sagen ja hat jetzt zwei mal nicht so gut
geklappt deswegen gehe ich jetzt direkt
in die mitte
wir sehen schon wir sind einander strand
bleibt und ich werde wieder so weit weg
laufen dich kann ich glaube das geht bis
da fordern etwa habe mir dort erstmal
die kisten an weil ich habe keinen bock
direkt wieder zu beginn zu sterben
überhaupt ist ich sehe ja alles okay da
vor der kiste schauen wir nach vorne
rein das einzige was ich wirklich
braucht ist ein schwert aber irgendwie
kann ich ja nicht madame ok in diamant
ok graßl der in meinem gebäude
reinlaufen ich glaube nicht dass tolle
zeit ich sehr genau wenn leute rein
laufen oder da kämpfen 200 euro auf den
linken
dass der gewinnt jetzt immer noch links
links also der mit dem hab ich was
gesagt hier draußen ist auf jeden fall
eine kiste wir haben hier ja ich brauche
halt eigentlich kein essen ne das
feuerzeug nämlich mal mit rauch zwar
nicht aber leider immer mal gebrauchen
den kern das ist nicht ich habe mich
gerade mit meinen part so gut halten
aber wir befinden uns direkt wieder in
einer neuen runde ich will einfach
weggelaufen ich will einfach nur eine
person töten in diesem ganzen video
meine ich das ist einfach mein einziges
ziel
ich mein ich brauche das ganze essen
nicht das brauche ich nicht theoretisch
gar nicht mitnehmen das ist total
unnötig weil ich direkt wieder sterben
werde
[Musik]
hart für mich
die zeiten gerade irgendwie schön
ich halte da minecraft spiel besonders
teil gestern bisschen dass auch schlimm
wenn mein herz gebrochen wird von diesen
ganzen profil ich meine aber vielleicht
gibt's ja wirklich daran dass ich
einfach eine extreme pussy bin und ich
muss einfach mal in die mitte laufen
von daher verfolge ich diesmal die
taktik also direkt los ich muss dir
entpacken schnell luca okay ich kann
kann ich immer töten sagt luca schlag
doch diese reagieren die nicht also
momentan eine rüstung an
jetzt stärkt es okay der hier vorne hat
auf jeden fall ein schwert allerdings
habe ich definitiv mehr rüstung ich
dachte ich dachte da werden nur er und
ich dachte der läuft zu und her
von wegen letzte team up and windy city
weswegen ich war folge wieder die taktik
denn so nah dran war ich wirklich noch
kein mal eine person irgendwie töten
von daher hier ist nun das zweimal vor
die kacke da krieg ich habe bessere
sachen wenn ich einfach zum ende der
mitläufer
tja ich schließlich ab ich schieße nicht
okay es geht noch nicht los von daher
ich laufe einfach mal los grace period
ended wie wikis enabled okay ich laufe
das war gar keine gute idee diesmal dann
die mitte zu gehen kommt springt ich
weiß ich habe leute hinter mir sind
deswegen ich laufe einfach mal so
schnell ich kann hier sind welche
treppen ich gehe mal nach links und
verstecke mich einfach hier und jetzt
liegen
so
ja
so sagen mein minecraft content vor fünf
jahren aus mal ein bisschen action jetzt
piste ok vielleicht hat mir das okay
geben wir haben kranke rüstung auf jeden
fall schon mal hier am start nicht so
krass aber für mich sind die kleinen
dinge im leben halt die erfolge und die
muss man auch respektieren und
wertschätzen
von daher würde ich sagen laufen als
einfach ein bisschen umkreis um den baum
herum
damit euch allen zu hause richtig schön
schlecht wie es wir visieren natürlich
weiter unser zorn gottes war was ist was
ist denn hier los gerade in der runde da
ist der halbmarathon als jede rinn
doch sie bei uns bei unseren neuen boots
ihr an das schwer packt man mal hierhin
eine hose auch oh mein gott kate zum
ersten mal eine richtige rüstung
komplett hier voll am start von daher
kann losgehen oder programme noch der
kiste und da ist auch ein besseres
schwerterin se ist nicht okay
die ganzen sachen die haben wir schon
relativ hoch hey wir können dort auch
noch eine kiste freunde was ist denn
hier los
er solle steinachs drin aber ich glaube
wir können in der jetzigen runde
wirklich was reißen denn hier sind
wirklich leute dabei
ich weiß nicht wer hier dabei ist aber
ich hatte noch in kleiner runde so ein
krank ist nun von alba die sagen machen
wir es mal ein bisschen action diesmal
kurz schwimmen gehen jetzt weiterhin die
wüste der ist ein typ der es auch gut
drauf der ist sehr gut drauf aber zack
das ist ja das ist ja ok das ist ja not
gegen elend ihr mann
ich dachte ich ende chance lasst mich
doch ein letztes mal versuche ich das
erdloch selected views plädiert es gibt
es
ich habe keine ahnung habe ich durch das
kind jetzt mein gott ich habe direkt
neuenstein schwertes gladiator kind
ausgewählt habe klasse danke für den
ablauf freude ich wusste es mich ich
habe gerade erst erfahren dass was das
hier
eine kiste wein und baut erst dann man
ich hab gerade erst erfahren das ist ein
kitzel action gibt aber ich bin auch
total blöd ich habe ja kein mal in frage
gestellt warum man dazu beginnen sondern
blatt papier daran dass einfach
akzeptiert so ja der hat ein blatt
papier da hat aber dass man da mit dem
kia gibt mir und ungebrochenes roos
schweinekotelett ja super ein paar
sekunden später o mein gott es ist auch
reversibel
wir sind freunde
mit der heutige video eine sache gezeigt
hat dass ich immer noch extrem
beschützen in minecraft bin an der
stelle mich der heutige wieso de/mobile
man jetzt mit luca jetzt allerdings auch
beenden meine lieben freunde die brille
ist abgesetzt deswegen ist das video
jetzt auch vorbei ich hoffe euch
gefallen wenn sie das getan hat las
gerne einen daumen hoch unter dem video
da und wir befinden uns jetzt auch schon
in der end karte meiner lieben freunde
ihr seht hier das spiel minecraft noch
mal angewendet da könnt ihr euch
herunterladen im google places könnt ihr
selber spiel das matte megaspaß auf
mandy nur leider bin ich halt nicht so
gut und ihr findet ja auch noch das
letzte mal beim mann ist mit luca video
eingeblendet ist leider nicht eine woche
her sondern zwei wochen weil ich krank
war
ich hoffe ihr versteht das und chelsea